la guerre c'est ça aussi au leximorose
29 ans a perdu son avant-bras il y a 5
mois à Kerson quant à nos but a frappé
son bataillon
ce camionneur de profession venait
d'être enrôlé dans l'armée ukrainienne
en avril
j'aurais pu perdre mes jambes aussi
au centre médical de prothèse et
d'orthèses en banlieue de Washington on
traite les cas les plus compliqués
Ukrainiens entame leur réhabilitation
physique
une rééducation qui prend normalement 6
à 8 mois à maîtriser
les exercices en Ukraine
ce sont des organisations caritatives
qui se chargent de leur séjour et
financent leur traitement
chaque prothèse coûte de 80 à 100000
dollars tous deux se souviennent de la
journée fatidique
romane Rho neuve a perdu tout son bras
gauche le 7 octobre à Logan à l'est de
l'Ukraine
un drone russe avait repéré son
bataillon dans une tranchée et ils se
sont fait bombarder
aujourd'hui il apprend à diriger son
bras artificiel grâce à un système
d'électrode
il communique avec sa prothèse à travers
ses muscles dit-il quand il les
contractent les signaux émis sont captés
par les électrodes qui les transmettent
au processus et dirige la main
avant la guerre romane travaillait dans
le domaine de la construction
je vais voir ce que je peux faire avec
ma prothèse dit-il quand je retournerai
en Ukraine je suis sûr que je vais
trouver quelque chose
rien ne va en ce moment là-bas dit-il
les bombardements se poursuivent près de
sa ville natale vénitia où se trouve sa
femme et sa fille de 5 ans
ils ont l'air si calme dit notre
interprète Olga ébranlé par cette guerre
mais à l'intérieur ils doivent bouillir
dit-elle ce sont vraiment des
a conçu ses nouvelles prothèses une
expertise qui s'est développée depuis
2005 avec l'arrivée de soldats
américains blessé en Irak et en
Afghanistan
je suis inquiet avec le conflit en
Ukraine dit-il car je n'y vois aucune
escalade
actuellement il estime à plus de 10000
le nombre de personnes amputées en
Ukraine à cause de la guerre
il y a beaucoup de soutien militaires
dit-il les munitions les tanks les armes
mais il n'y a pas de soutien médical et
malheureusement en temps de guerre les
gens se blessent
avec la guerre qui s'intensifie le
nombre d'amputés ne peut qu'augmenter